[Aplausos]
[Música]
con ustedes
arranca el 9 10 y 10 35 cuando
continuidad cinco años
dice tan sombrías
en ese momento recibí mi primera todo
acceder es como regalo
un niño
un sitio jugaba con mi madre mi hermana
mis amigos varios amigos no era más que
una pretensión de divertirme como todos
los niños negras
el tiempo después llevando entre los 12
años aprender a escribir y desaprender
el código alfanumérico que permite dar
las partidas
y a partir se aumente un camino sin
retorno será posible ver las grandes
partidas de los grandes maestros
con los comentarios de estos y otros
grandes que me permitía prácticamente
quedar en su mente y descubrir las ideas
que lo que daban a la hora de actuar
es fascinante poder ingresar en la mente
de otra persona y eso se empezó a
traducir en resultados deportivos
a través del estudio logré salir
mejoraba hasta llegar al lado de los
años donde puede imperar por primera vez
la selección nacional de ajedrez
a los olímpicos y no puedo estar
haciendo ocasiones incluso en una de
ellas el año 2006 de vitalidad de buena
posibilidad de ganar 7 partidas
consecutivas
mantener la medalla del tercer tablero
aún hoy día siento emoción cuando veo la
clasificación
de uruguay arriba de los
países más encumbrados es una
experiencia única para que no bien para
muchos
de mi compañero de equipo y mis
compañeros de disciplina ya compartido
nos tenían pocos míos
pero no es sobre el vigoroso solicito
que veía a blades hoy sino de lo que son
como especie de realización que me
permite aprender
y el ajedrez
podría ser aplicado a otros campos
indicación particular la bomba cia en
espacio legal de profesión y cuando
entré a participar en la vida cívica
también a la actividad política y
publique una forma de entender esta
realidad que se sirve para partir
cuando uno bajo la partida es pérez
eres una prima del año
es
y el color y posición que ocupa
para poder justamente tener la situación
estrategia uno toma sus decisiones según
él no tiene por qué estar
blancas
y esto siempre ha llevado a la discusión
que es mejor en realidad cualquier
jugador de ajedrez sabe que deberá
enfrentar
de muchas
de esa manera en muchas ocasiones
esto
mayor incluso es tenido que manejar la
misma posición defendiendo un bando u
otro
esto tiene mucho que publica y siempre
lo tomo como ejemplo a través de mi
caída profesional
como muchas veces me toca defender al
alrededor
otros años algunas veces al trabajador
otra es a limpiador
y es esa habilidad en el juego
de verdad esa dualidad existe en el
ámbito profesional sin saber que existe
un otro que tiene su punto de vista tan
respetuoso
si nos llevamos altamente al campo
político también observarán que sucede
esto y música
de izquierda a derecha
aquellos que tenían desarrollo económico
pero muy picante estos días en el tema
de las tradiciones de nuestro animal
y donde quiera que miremos vamos a ver
esas blancas hileras
de la sociedad esa dualidad
y justamente nos lleva a tener esa
capacidad
cómo poder superar esta habilidad de
aportar algo
una vez más de ellos pero si uno va
alejando la visión
verdes del tablero hacia arriba
llevaría los puntos empieza a
interceptar y muchas veces estas
diferencias que entendemos que son
insalvables se convierten en simplemente
cuestiones semánticas sobre las que
podemos trabajar
egipto
es el primer punto y quería compartir
con ustedes la primera idea
en esas había necesitado de éxitos a
otro lado
la segunda cuestión que elegiría
plantear es una pregunta
y en nada la partida de pensar
y para ganar hay que saber la estrategia
pero esto no es así como la misma clase
un famosísimo jugador de ajedrez es
casualmente también abogado
se llama
él dijo una frase que marca a todos los
expertos a la crisis
echamos
el grado
ya sabemos que esto está el cargador de
la partida es el jugador que comete el
penúltimo error
el elemento característico de cualquier
partida de ajedrez como elemento
característico de cualquier ser humano
es justamente es
y logramos y lo que hace la partida de
ajedrez única es repetirlo
tenemos que aceptar esa condición
decir eso esas facilidades para
justamente entender
aceptarnos y perdonarnos los errores que
comentamos en el juego
también aceptar como parte de ellos los
errores que juegan con nuestro estado
ensayos y savannah y eso estará siempre
ahí incluso una está por tiene otra
frase que dice no es a ti nos están
alimenta vieron tres títulos cometas que
también es un aspecto va en un sentido
similar
el tema del error evidentemente se
aplica a todas las áreas
como abogado no me gustaría pero muchas
veces los juicios se terminan
muchas veces también se equivocan los
jueces
muchas veces
cometemos errores en nuestra vida
cotidiana
y nos llevan
a pensar el abatimiento
pero otras veces tenemos que otros
seguimos almas
es la condición humana y tenemos que
aceptarlo
podemos entrar también en el campo
político
y si yo tenía pensado exijamos ejemplo
voy a dejar que ustedes
en ese ejercicio único de la
espiritualidad piense y seguramente
sabrá de corazón risas sobre errores que
han cometido grandes
y no somos grandes líderes políticos y
también locales evidentes nacionales
siempre el alma de lo que nos hace
humanos es una cuestión que tenemos que
tener muy presente y no solo
hablo de campos de ciencia sociales
también en lo que son las ciencias
físicas duras como puede llamarse han
existido errores que ha aparecido
grandes descubrimientos
en 1928
la felicidad puede contar por un olvido
de freddy que dejó después de vacaciones
y cuando vio lo que haría las bacterias
habían y matados
a las pastillas que dan infecciones y
justamente seguros a las miles de vidas
por ese error humano
la cocacola también termina siendo un
producto de un error
en la iniciación y un ejemplo quizás muy
dormido de final
esto nos lleva a la siguiente paz
arrancamos ocupando las blancas o negras
un lugar u otro nos equivocaremos como
seres humanos pero todos dirigidos
hacia un momento especial
para aquellos que saben de ajedrez en el
trabajo de aquellos
[Música]
dejaría mate es el final de la partida
de ajedrez es el objetivo del juego
viene de una palabra de origen persa que
se dice ya max y que significa el rey ha
muerto
aunque su
traducción más literal sería el rey no
tiene escapatoria
esto indudablemente
es el final de la partida de ajedrez
en el mundo del derecho tenemos
un equivalente al jaque mate que es la
cosa juzgada
incluso los autores romanos cuando
empezaron a extraer esto decían y la
cosa juzgada convertir a lo redondo un
cuadrado y lo cuadrado en redondo y que
hacía de lo blanco o negro
indudablemente
este concepto tan válido para el mundo
de ajedrez y el derecho en la sociedad
moderna hoy prácticamente no es
admisible
hoy en día
y nuestra condición en el siglo 21 está
reviendo constantemente nuestras
opiniones nuestras valoraciones
es un poco lo que nos viene despertando
este nuevo tiempo de las ideas
justamente ante esta capacidad de
arreglar las cosas es que
más cuesta aplicar el concepto de jaque
mate tradicional a lo que es hagan el
ejercicio intelectualmente ustedes de
ver cuántas cosas que consideraban
verdades firmes ayer ya no lo son
ganar el ejercicio intelectual
de pensar dentro de 10 15 20 30 años
basta con
recordar la época no existía celular
para tener presente estos cambios
vertiginosos de la historia
pero jaque mate
a todos xerecista aprende una lección
que quizás está oculta y quizás se hará
más importante que tengamos que aprender
es un poco la que les quería dejar
la partida de ajedrez termina con el
jaque mate
pero apenas terminó una partida
deberemos
empezando a seguir
la federación internacional de ajedrez
tiene un lema
si se dice el latín es una suma y
significa somos una familia
esto nos pone nuestra condición de seres
humanos y que todos en definitiva somos
jugadores en el tablero de la vida
ya sea la disciplina que practiquemos la
actividad cotidiana la actividad siga
que esté hemos pretendido analizar
somos una familia
somos todos
partes de esta comunidad que nos reúne
aquí y que no puede entender
de separaciones todos cometemos errores
todos estamos aquí estamos aquí reunidos
justamente porque queremos compartir
ideas
como yo les pido que acepten mis errores
de esta charla ustedes también
tendrán algunos errores que puedan haber
cometido
pero en la línea argumental y esto lo
que diríase en señalar
sea el lado preocupemos
blancos o negros tomemos las decisiones
correctas o no
el error es parte del juego
estemos de al lado
de la victoria de jaque mate o dorado de
la derrota
sepamos que el jaque mate es
solamente el fin de la partida y no es
el fin de nada sino el comienzo de un
nuevo todo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]